- Well, I can't help, but notice
that in SWAT and in Criminal Minds
your character loves to kick in doors.
(laughing)
And I just need, before
you even talk about it,
I need you to know that I
have kicked in the door.
- Oh, have you?
- I have kicked in a
door that a contractor
had to come to our house
and replace the door.
- Okay.
- Because the first time I was,
whenever I was with my ex
and it was the first time
I was watching his
children and we were dating
and I got locked in my bathroom.
(laughing)
And I was like, what?
- Did he lock you in the bathroom?
How, no, he was gone.
(laughing)
It was my first time
like taking care of them
and I was freaking out 'cause I was like,
this is not happening on my watch.
I literally kicked the door down in,
in my bathroom in my house.
- Isn't that a good feeling though?
- You know what,
- Isn't it, come on.
- You know what I gotta tell you,
if you can afford it, try it.
(laughing)
Like you saying, it felt really good
and, and it also like,
it was funny 'cause
the contractor is like,
you're allowed to watch
my children any time
(laughing)
'cause I was like, this is
not happening on my watch,
but it does, it feels so powerful.
- Oh yeah, no
- Yes.
- I mean on my last show, Criminal Minds,
- Yeah.
- Derek Morgan, there was a stint
where 'cause the first
season they had me in suits
and like just--
- Oh that would be hard.
- They had like grandpa clothes
- Yeah.
- And I was like,
yo, I'm athletic.
- Yeah.
- You know, put me in the jeans
and the t-shirt I'm physical.
And so once they figured it out
and took a chance that
I could run and jump
and do this stuff, all of a sudden I was,
it seemed like every other episode,
I was either tackling
somebody for no reason,
- Yeah.
- or I was kicking down doors.
They actually gave me a nickname,
captain kicked door down,
captain kicked door down guy.
(laughing)
- That's a long one.
- So every episode I was like, FBI!
And slam through a door
and what was funny is every time
we would kick through the door,
then I'd go, FBI!
And the next word out of
my mouth would be, clear.
'Cause we were always late.
They were always gone.
They're already gone.
So I already did the tough guy stuff,
but there was nothing there.
- No, I love that though.
That seems like such a fun job
and it seems like such a fun team
- Oh we had a ball.
- y'all hang out
off the set too, that's so cool.
- Just, I mean,
I don't think there's a lot of shows
like ours on television.
I, you know, I'm biased, but,
but what is the motto when SWAT,
we help those who can't
help them, we help those
who can't help themselves.
- Help themselves.
- SWAT is not about kicking
ass, it's about saving lives.
- Yeah, I love that.
- Street, street, street!
(laughing)
Never be in a hurry to die!
- You got tough all of a sudden.